would be interesting to see what people
watching on Sky News Made of it all I'm
actually interested to get the take of
our views panel this evening on the
strikes to have sympathy with workers do
they actually think that the government
needs to do more to try and stand up to
the unions let's find out shall we can
go to Roy first Roya conservative voter
talking to us from Kent this evening uh
Roy here's your sympathy with when it
comes to train strikes
um the passenger basically I think this
is more about politics than pay at the
moment Mick Lynch has a as an ax to
grind Spanish practices need to be taken
care of yes they need to be paid more
there is a problem about baking in
inflation I think that is a that is a
real issue
um and we take a short-termest view as
always for the last six years we've been
taking a short-termness view of of of
um
of policy
um I'm not thinking about the long term
um and I think it started with the rail
unions it will move to other public
sector pay and um we're going to bake in
inflation it's I'm just sort of
hunkering down for another six or eight
years of pain basically economically
speaking interesting I mean that did
really you know Echo with what Mark
Harper was saying about how you can't
embed inflation into pay expectations
let's go to Rod's next hour to see what
your take is on this Roz McMullen at
Labor voter from York whose side are you
on when it comes to the real dispute
well I'm on the side of working people
and the working people in this instance
um are the members of the rmt some of
whom are extremely poorly paid
and I mean when you listen to Nick Lynch
and then you listen to the Tory
government it's quite obvious who who
you trust who's telling the truth when I
heard Rishi sunak today at Prime
Minister's questions the Cure accused
que stalma of being on the side of the
unions and not on the side of working
people I thought he needs a history
lesson he needs a civics lesson who the
heck does he think the unions are and
it's as if they're trying the government
are trying to pretend that we are 50
years ago uh it's it's totally bizarre
the rich are getting richer the poorer
getting poorer we've had 12 years of
Tory government
five Prime Ministers seven chancellors
and it's a mess it is a mess they have
destroyed the economy and they are
making life extremely difficult for
working people and I think we are in for
a very very difficult time but what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to turn workers against workers and
frankly that is not going to work I
don't think the British public are going
to be fooled by that one job right well
that's two very contrasting views there
on the strikes that's bringing Kevin
shall we Kevin burden he's talking to us
at from Cardiff if you describe yourself
as a voter from the left
um do you think that rail workers should
get an inflation uh mashing pay rise
well I think it's inevitable that all
workers will want to try and keep up
with inflation it's running away I I'm
um
we sold a house
um a year ago and and had the money in
the bank we're desperate desperate to
buy a new house because the value of the
money was uh eeking away so you know
whether you're a worker you're a
pensioner or you rely on savings it's a
terrible time to be
um trying to make ends meet I mean I I
what happened a year ago is that we
moved from England to Wales and um you
know one of the first things we noticed
was how much better public transport is
here the trains are better there are
more buses there are more services
they're more frequent they're more
reliable and um it does seem to suggest
that there's something different about
the way it's organized I don't think
public ownership is a Panacea the the
the the the
um the public transport is largely run
through the Welsh government here
um I don't think it's a Panacea I
remember British Rail
um but it does suggest that a different
model and a different approach does have
some success and it's less likely
perhaps to lead to conflict interesting
stuff there about the actual standards
you know on our Railways muttering as
well as the kind of pay dispute uh too
right let's bring in Belinda shower now
Belinda you're talking to us from
Twickenham in Southwest uh London at
your swing voter aren't you so which way
do you swing when it comes to the rail
strikes
well I went to Inverness um on Sunday
night and came back on Monday night and
if any of the other trains hadn't worked
it would have ruined my whole trip I've
booked another ticket in December and so
just never knowing whether anything's
going to go ahead or not it's really
upsetting I'm worrying for people when
things go wrong for workers for students
when strikes keep going on so long it it
nobody's meeting in the middle so the
the government and the and the trade
unions nobody's meeting in the middle
people are either being stubborn or
they're just not coming up with a
solution of any kind whatsoever so I
think you know damaging passengers lives
workers lives you know there comes a
point where maybe you should only be
able to strike so many times there's got
to be maybe a cap on how many times you
can actually strike yeah certainly
important isn't it talking about you
know the impact is having on people a
particular course in the right after
Christmas as well um is our battery
charger let's go to you next you're
talking to us from London
um what's your position when it comes to
the rail strikes do you have sympathy
with the rmt
yeah I actually do have sympathy with
the rmt I think the the rail strikes are
obviously going to be disruptive for me
but that's kind of the whole point and
if you look at most rmt members they've
not had a real terms pay increase for
years that they're not your kind of
relatively comfortable tube drivers
those are represented by a different
Union and so actually looking at a a pay
rise which is still less than the
inflation rate it feels not crazy
unreasonable for me and the the
disruption I think is something that I'm
kind of willing to stomach given the the
cost of living crisis and the kind of
reasonable ask for a pay increase uh
right let's talk to John then shall we
finally uh John Comerford a conservative
voter you're talking to us from Ashbury
in Kent John do you have sympathy with
the rmt or are you concerned about the
disruption the stripes might cause
I'm very disturbed about the passenger
and the disruption that they're going to
suffer
um the timing
I know they've had these strikes on for
a long time but I think the time in this
latest lot will bring probably the worst
disruption as far as people are
concerned and I'm just disappointed that
the government who I you know I do
support I'd like to see Mark Harper get
there tomorrow and bang a few heads
together as opposed to uh
you know just just saying he's going to
facilitate something he's a very good MP
he's certainly done well over the years
let's see him come to the the table
tomorrow and try and get a result before
these strikes start there you go I can
see a couple of her panel members
nodding along with that part of your
answer Johns though I think there's a
bit of agreement there uh in uh hoping
for a last minute resolution thank you
so much all of you for giving your views
on the rail strike something I'm sure at
many people at home are going to have
concerns about as well